Transcriber: Pelin Gürcü
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Ben de bir Koç Lisesi mezunuyum
ve okuluma
mümkün olduğunca geri dönmek,
bu tarz etkinlikler aracılığıyla,
beni gerçekten çok mutlu ediyor.
Ben TEDx konuşmaları izlemeyi
gerçekten çok severim
boş zamanlarımda
ve çoğundan da
çok etkili öğretilerle,
çıkarımlarla ayrılırım.
O yüzden kendi yaşantımdan
olabildiğince kısa bir sürede
sizin hayatınıza en kalıcı
ne aktabilirim diye uzun uzun düşündüm.
Hatta doğrusunu söylemek gerekirse
son zamanlarda hiçbir şeye bu kadar
fazla kafa yormamıştım.
Benim en tutkulu ve bilgili olarak
yaptığım şey aslında
gençleri, öğrencileri,
yaşça yakın olduğum arkadaşlarımı,
STEM bölümlerine teşvik etmektir
ve heyecanlandırmaktır.
Hobi olarak bu tarz içerikler paylaşırım
ve öğrenciler için STEM etkinliklerine
katılmayı çok severim.
O yüzden dedim acaba yaptığım işlerden
mi bahsetsem size.
Bilim temalı, heyecan verici buluşlardan
ve araştırmalardan mı bahsetsem
acaba diye düşünürken
size kendi uzmanlık alanımın
çok dışında,
hatta akademik açıdan
hiçbir bilgimin de olmadığı
ama yaşanmışlıklarımdan yola çıkarak
söylecek çok sözümün olduğu,
bir konuda konuşmak istiyorum;
o da insan ilişkileri.
Bir de, sizden gelen biri olarak
biraz daha informal,
doğrudan işimle alakalı olmayan
ve samimi bir konuşma
yapmak istedim
ve temayla da ilgilendirerek,
mesafe ile ilgili olsun istedim.
Bu yüzden hepimizin hayatlarında var olan
ama çok da üstüne düşünmediğimiz,
mesafeler üzerine konuşacağım.
Eğer bilim alanında bu arada, kariyer ve
eğitim odaklı sorularınız varsa
ve destek isterseniz,
bana bu konuda bu konuşmadan sonra
hiç çekinmeden, her zaman ulaşabilirsiniz.
Ama şimdilik diğer konuya atlıyorum.
Birazcık lisenin sonrasında neler yaptım,
lise sonrasındaki hayatımı
özet geçmek gerekirse
2016 yılında Koç’tan mezun oldum,
üniversitede Amerika’ya
Johns Hopkins Üniversitesine gittim.
Mezun olduktan sonra da Boston’a taşınıp
Harvard Medical School’da
bir laboratuvarda çalışmaya başladım.
Az önce bahsettiğiniz gibi,
çeşitli virüslerin teşhis teknolojileri
üzerine çalışıyordum.
En son projem de
Kovid-19 tanı kiti teknolojisi üzerineydi.
Hayatımı, bir bilim insanı olmak yönünde
ilerletmek istiyorum,
şu anda bu doğrultuda araştırmalarıma,
eğitimime devam ediyorum.
Gelecek yılda bir yüksek lisans programına
başlamayı planlıyorum.
Mesafe kavramı sanki covid’den itibaren
hayatımızı istila etmiş gibi geliyor.
Ama mesafeler aslında
hepimizin hayatında her zaman vardı
ve her mesafenin bizi zorladığı,
bize bir şeyler kattığı,
öğrettiği, tanıttığı noktalar hep olmuştu
covid’den önce de.
Hayatımıza girmiş çıkmış insanlarla
aramızda
her zaman fiziksel ve
duygusal mesafeler bulunuyordu.
Benim için de,
hayatımın mesafe dolu dönemi,
üniversiteye, Amerika’ya
gitmemle başladı.
Önce doğal olarak ailemle aramıza giren
mesafenin farkına varmaya başladım.
Sonradan da lise ve
çocukluk arkadaşlarımla
aramıza giren mesafenin.
Kabul etmek istemeseniz de,
hiç öyle olmayacakmış gibi gelse de,
fiziksel mesafe ikili insan ilişkilerini
değiştiriyor.
Aranızda yatılı okuyanlarınız varsa
bunu daha erken bir yaştan yaşamaya
başlamış olabilirsiniz.
Ailenizden ve çocukluk arkadaşlarınızdan
fiziki bir kopuşu
şimdiden tatmışsınızdır belki.
Ve eğer bu mesafelerin
şimdiden farkındaysanız,
aslında bence çok şanslısınız.
Çünkü mesafe kavramının bilincine varmak
hayatınıza çok güzel bir ilişki katıyor
ve birazdan o ilişkiye geleceğim.
Biz hayatımızdaki kişilerle
olan mesafeleri
kısa tutmak için
çoğunlukla gayret gösteririz.
Meselai bir arkadaşınla aranın açıldığını
düşünürsen ne yaparsın?
Hemen bir mesaj atar arar, “Hadi
gel arayı kapatalım” dersin.
Ya da örneğin; uzaktasın ve
annenin, bir akrabanın
hasta olduğunu öğrendin,
eğer imkânlar, zaman ve mekân
el veriyorsa ne yaparsın?
Gerekirse uçar, gerekirse koşar
annenin, akrabanın,
kimse artık o, yanına gidersin.
Aranızdaki mesafeyi sıfıra indirip
yanında olabilmek,
ona yardımcı olabilmek,
ona dokunabilmek istersin.
Peki, kendine en son ne zaman sordun?
Herhangi bir soru,
en son kendine ne zaman sordun?
Ben iyi miyim?
Ne kadar iyiyim?
Bir şeye ihtiyacım var mı?
Ben ne kadar benim?
Kendimle aram açıldı mı?
Eğer açıldığını fark ettiysem,
kendime olan yolları kat etmek,
dağları, mesafeleri sıfıra indirmek için
en son ne zaman uğraştım?
En son ne yaptım?
İşte kendimize olan
mesafemiz böyle bir mesafe.
Kendimizle olan ilişkimiz
böyle bir ilişki.
Çoğunlukla gerekli özeni göstermediğimiz,
hatta üzerine pek de
kafa yormadığımız bir ilişki türü.
Sevdiklerimizle
aramızdaki mesafelerden başladım.
Sonra konuyu kendimizle olan
ilişkimize getirdim.
Neden?
Çünkü insan yalnız kalınca ancak kendiyle
olan mesafesini sorgulamaya başlıyor.
Başkalarına olan mesafesi,
ancak tavan
yaptığında kendine dönmeye başlıyor.
Genelleme yapmayayım tabii,
ama benim için böyle oldu.
Hayatıma ne zaman mesafeler girdi,
ne zaman Amerika’ya gittim
ve sevdiklerimden uzak kalmaya başladım,
o zaman kendimi tanımaya ve
kendimi dinlemeye başladım.
Bu, tabii ki bir günde olmadı.
Uzun ve hâlâ devam eden bir süreç
ve zor bir süreç.
Ama bir farkındalıkla başlıyor,
her şeyde olduğu gibi
ve tabii ki, sizin kendinizle olan
ilişkinizi keşfetmeniz için
illa ki okyanus aşmanıza gerek yok.
Hatta ayrı bir eve bile
çıkmanıza gerek yok.
Sadece uzaklaşmak, yalnız kalmak,
kendini tanıma sürecini
zorunlu hâle getiriyor.
Sizle bu konuyu konuşmak istememin
sebebi de tam olarak bu.
Siz zorunda kalmadan,
bir okul, bir iş,
yeni bir hayat kurmak için
uzaklara gitmek zorunda kalmadan önce
kendinizle farklı bir diyalog kurmaya,
kendinize olan mesafenizi tanımaya
başlayabilirsiniz.
Hatta çok da iyi edersiniz.
Hayatımızın bir parçası olan insanlara
her zaman bir mesafe uzakta olacağız.
Bu mesafeler biz yaşadıkça bazen artacak,
bazen azalacak, bazen de değişecek ve
senin bu mesafelere karşı diyebileceğin,
hiçbir şey alabileceğin hiçbir önlem,
koyabileceğin hiçbir barikat kalmayacak.
Covid’de zaten hepimizin gördüğü gibi.
Ama sen kiminle olan mesafeni her zaman
kontrol altında tutabilirsin?
Kendin.
Kiminle olan mesafeni sadece
kendi çabanla yok edebilirsin?
Sadece kendinle.
Özetlemem gerekirse
mesafeler covid’li veya covid’siz,
hayatımızda hep var olacak
ve biz de hem kendimiz
hem de sevdiklerimizle olan
mesafemiz istediğimiz uzaklıkta
ve yakınlıkta,
bir dengede tutmayı
öğrenmek zorunda olacağız.
İnsan yalnız kalınca kendiyle konuşmak,
kendine soru sormak ve kendini dinlemek
zorunda kalıyor.
Ama sen şimdiden
kendinle bu diyalogları başlatarak
kendinin ilk yardım çantası olmayı
öğrenebilirsin.
Kendinle olan mesafen, en önemli mesafen
ve her şart altında en kısa tutman
gereken mesafen.
Daima en yakın kendine ol.
Kendine sorular sor.
“Benim yardıma, insana, zamana,
bir dokunuşa ihtiyacım var mı?” diye
açık açık sor kendine.
Cevaplarını
bekle ve gerçekten dinle.
Kendine, bir başkasına
hatta küçük bir çocuğa
göstereceğin merhameti göster.
Yardıma ihtiyacın olduğunda,
kendi yardımına herkesten önce
koşmayı öğren.
Kontrol altında tutup her şart altında en
yakınında tutabileceğin,
sana her şart
altında destek olabilecek tek ilişki,
kendinle olan ilişkin olacak.
Bu da başlı başına çok güzel bir şey.
Teşekkür ederim.